i hope to see you again
soon
i hope that
all of us
will stay alive
i really hope that my husband comes back
home
the woman you just saw was ukrainian
youtuber elena ganesh and like many
people in kiev she hunkers down in a
bomb shelter when the city's strict
curfew goes into effect now elena joins
me now live from that bomb shelter
elena um we just heard you talk about
your husband
and i know he's out there and i know
he's prepared to fight
uh when was the last time you talked
with him
uh in the evening so right now it's like
early morning
and we talked before the night yes
and
he said that it will be
fine elena you're clutching your baby
and your arms uh
and i know there's so many children
especially
in the uh underground in the metro uh
area that is being used as an extensive
bomb shelter for tens of thousands
of ukrainians
basic questions about food
and milk and
supplies medicines
do you have those basic necessities
tonight as you don't know how long this
is going to go on
well you see for for today for tomorrow
we have enough we have enough maybe even
for like a week we have enough but
i don't think we have more
those ukrainians tonight
those ukrainians tonight elena who
have not had the chance to reach their
loved ones their brothers or their
uncles
their husbands
um
that is the i mean that's
unspeakably difficult
not knowing
what happens next
how hard has that been for your friends
and others
who've
perhaps lost touch with those who've
remained a fight
guys i think we know what's going to
happen next and somebody already told on
tv right now to to you yes that they are
going to make a steel ring and just
arrange a massacre
here so i think we know what's going to
happen we know that we have enough food
just for one week we know that we do not
we have like
the water enough for one week
and
that if
that's going to happen we know that
putin uh
will not conquer ukraine but if he
conquers ukraine he will not be able to
hold it
and this is why he is going just to
heal the most of the local population
who is that who didn't run away
and this is how he is going to hold
ukraine so he is going to make here
genocide the massacre
so we know what's going to happen
elena did you
try to leave
ukraine or did you make a decision
that you were not going to
i had enough of fuel i had we had a car
with fuel and everything but we decided
to stay because if we run away from our
home
you will not come instead of us and
protect our home right
so it's first of all
first of all our responsibility to
protect our home now if i left and
left all these people behind me here in
the city all these women children and
men because for me the life of men and
women it's equally important
you know i feel pity for everyone or was
women and
women and men if i left all of them here
and did not everything possible to save
them i just wouldn't be able to live
with it you know anywhere in the us and
france it's good to travel for vacations
but you know just
run away and know that
you left behind
your people to die
i wouldn't just survive with it and i
don't want my children to live with it
you know i just stay and i do whatever
it takes i still hope
i still hope that we
will be saved that we will
win
and but for this we need we need help
we really need urgent help
no-fly zone
immediate intervention
something like this
and if you guys are afraid to make putin
angry and provoke him you see ukrainians
were not provoking anyone
he just attacked do you think this do
you elena do you think
this situation was needlessly provoked
that putin was provoked by desire for
nato expansion or
some type of failed
leadership along the line
no
this is what i'm saying we were not
provoking putin it was not provoked
it was just
he just doesn't want ukraine to be an
independent country he that he just
doesn't doesn't believe ukrainian nation
exists and he clearly said i mean if we
say okay we are not ukrainian we will be
russians only in this case
he is not provoked i mean it's not in
conversation it's not
negotiation it's just i want you
to obey i want you to be to be under my
control control and if you are not under
control i will kill you
this is the conversation elena so what
should you do no
elena
you know
we're all praying for you and we're
praying for the ukrainian people and
your children and all the children of
ukraine i'm afraid
prayers are not i'm not enough but thank
you
no well you need supplies and you need
ammunition elena thank you
we're going to have more breaking news
from the war in ukraine i have
ammunition
instead of a baby and go and kill them
yes but it would be great to have some
no-fly zone so not only gun in my hand
because i'm holding a baby right now
thank you
elena thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else